with more twists on a razor wire Maze
and a seriously eye popping story saw X
is a lot to take in but don't get stuck
in the worst trap of all confusion
here's the ending explained spoilers
ahead trust
me you will want to remain alert most
Saw movies are fairly straightforward
bad people get caught by jigsaw and put
into horrific traps saw X follows the
same basic formula but it asks the
audience to invest way more in its plot
and characters at the heart of the movie
is John Kramer himself have been the
figure looming over every movie in the
past but this time around he's the
center of attention in a way he's never
been before the movie opens with Jon
struggling to deal with his cancer
treatment he sees doctors and goes to
support groups but he refuses to really
accept what's happening to him John runs
into a man named Henry who used to
attend his support group but has now
been miraculously cured Henry tells JN
about the special illegal treatments he
received from an experimental doctor and
Jon is sold after doing some research
online John connects with Cecilia
Peterson the daughter of Henry's doctor
Cecilia tells John that she's Contin
continuing her father's work at a secret
medical facility in Mexico City John
wastes no time going there but a few
days after his treatment he figures out
that Cecilia faked his surgery and stole
his money enraged Jon Taps into his
inner jigsaw and begins laying plans
with the help of a mysterious man on the
phone Jon finds the scammers Amanda
Young comes to Mexico to help JN carry
out his plans they capture Valentina
Mato Gabriella and Cecilia while JN and
Amanda Force everyone into their traps
another victim of the scam named Parker
Sears shows up trying to get his money
back he's horrified by what sees but
gets roped into Jon's games Valentina
and Mato both die in their traps but
Gabriella manages to survive as Jon is
getting ready to prepare Cecilia for her
trap the movie's big twist happens it
turns out that Parker was working with
Cecilia all along the two of them
capture JN and Amanda and Cecilia kills
Gabriella herself then she captures a
young boy from the fake Clinic who
befriended Jon and she puts the two of
them into Jon's final trap together
while Jon and the boy are basically
drowning to death in blood Cecilia and
Parker search Jon's makeshift office for
all the money from the scam when they
find it the Trap goes off John and the
boy are free but Cecilia and Parker are
locked in the office while toxic gas
fills the room Cecilia murders Parker to
fulfill the trap's game and save herself
the movie ends with John Amanda and the
boy leaving Cecilia barely alive in the
office as both a sequel and a prequel
saw X finds itself in a bit of a trap
its story needed to fit between saw and
Saw 2 so the ending couldn't introduce
any wild changes for the franchise as a
whole that doesn't necessarily mean that
the entire story was pointless though
the ending of the movie might actually
have a big impact on how people view
John Kramer in his serial killer Persona
the events of Saw x per it again that
Jon is fully committed to his demented
moral code his Twisted mind doesn't view
what he does as actually killing people
he really does think putting people in
these horrible traps makes them atone
for their sins we all have free will
when Cecilia kills Gabriella Jon is
horrified because he genuinely views her
murder as different from his trap her
victim never got a choice when cilia
takes things a step further by
threatening a child Jon is outraged
whereas Cecilia is a true sociopath who
cares about no one but herself Jon is
apparently able to form real connections
with people the ending of sawx tries to
show us that Jon isn't exactly a monster
that might be hard to swallow after
nearly two decades of Saw movies but
who's to say that psychotic Killers
can't also have hearts of gold the first
saw introduced the world to John Kramer
and he'd already racked up a concerning
amount of victims by the time that movie
ended jigsaws methods were already
getting attention as established by the
wall of newspaper clippings detective
tapad but that doesn't necessarily mean
that people all around the world would
know who he was we know that jigsaw was
a famous killer before the franchise had
a chance to really get rolling near the
end of Saw X Cecilia spends some time
gloating over the fact that she's now
beat him twice and her villainous
monologue holds a little surprise it
turns out that Cecilia knows exactly who
jigsaw is as a sociopath herself Cecilia
is a bit Starstruck to be dealing with
Jigsaw and she's particularly delighted
to have bested a famous serial killer
maybe it isn't surprising that jigsaw
gained worldwide infamy so quickly after
all there are hardly any other famed
Killers who use methods as specific and
grotesque now it's clear that Jon's
reputation doesn't just help him acquire
loyal acolytes and also create psychotic
Rivals for him to compete with Henry is
the man from John's support group who
first told him about the secret cancer
curing treatment supposedly developed by
Cecilia's father after setting Jon on
the course to Mexico City Henry
basically disappears from the movie The
Back hour of the film is dedicated to JN
locking all the scam artists and
gruesome traps but Henry is nowhere to
be seen only the most patient audience
members get to find out what eventually
happens to Henry a man as smart as John
Kramer isn't about to forget when
someone has wronged him a mid credit
scene reveals that John circled back to
Henry after returning to the United
States John is Henry trapped in the very
same bathroom from the original saw
Henry has a nasty looking bladed device
strapped to his body the scene cuts the
black before his game gets underway
unless it's a plot hole however remember
that in Saw 2 which is chronologically
after saw X the remains of Adam and Zep
were still in the bathroom maybe Henry
made it out after all you don't need to
understand the entire saw franchise time
line to follow what's happening in Saw x
a newcomer to the franchise could still
enjoy the movie though they might walk
away with a few questions about how
Jon's Associates fit into the story but
even franchise super fans might have
some questions about how saw X factors
into the larger timeline saw X is set
between the events of Saw and saw two
but there are a few moments in the movie
that seemingly confuse that chronology
but may actually have explanations after
getting this fake treatment Jon is
doodling in his notebook working on a
sketch of the rack from Saw 3 and
because he scraps the drawing it makes
sense why the Trap doesn't appear in the
franchise right away in the movie's mid
credit scene Jon is back in the room
from Saw and it does seem strange that
he would return to a place that could
potentially be considered an active
crime scene by investigators the actual
explanation is that there is very little
time between the events of Saw and saw X
so John apparently still has his old
workshops available to him this movie
happens weeks after the end of saw one
saw X happens over the course of only a
few days and that might explain why this
story from John's past has never been
alluded to before now it's a blip in his
entire murderous timeline although an
eventful one Jon wouldn't have been able
to pull off his scheme in Mexico City
without help Amanda young one of Jon's
acolytes gets some time in the Limelight
but Jon's other collaborator is a bit
more mysterious on multiple occasions
throughout the film Jon gets on the
phone and asks someone on the other end
to help him locate one of the scam
artists a man's voice replies but it
doesn't say much and even the most
hardcore saw fans might not have
recognized the character from The Voice
alone the mid- credit scene finally puts
him on screen and it turns out to be
Hoffman a man with whom long time saw
fans are intimately familiar Hoffman has
had an extremely important role in the
series he's able to help JN because he
works for the police and that also makes
him an especially dangerous man To Be A
Serial Killer's loyal follower the
ending of sawx shows us that Hoffman's
history with johon might go back even
further than initially thought of all
the men to chat you pick John Kramer as
far as the story is concerned saw X make
some revolutionary changes to the
franchises formula because it's set
between the events of two previous
movies it really isn't able to tread
much new ground and doesn't do very much
to set up yet another installment in the
series technically it already has a
sequel and saw two in fact because the
movie spends so much effort returning to
the franchise's roots and exploring the
inner mindset of John Kramer it would
actually make for a pretty great sendoff
to the entire series chances are good
that saw X won't be the end of the
franchise though while the in Universe
future of Saw may very much be a mystery
it's pretty clear that the franchise
still has some life left in it upon
release saw X is the best reviewed movie
in the entire series and the first movie
in the series to get a positive score on
rot tomatoes that could mean saw is
turning a new leaf and there could be a
slew of critically successful movies yet
to come ultimately like everything else
in the movie business the future of Saw
depends on how much money it can
generate if enough fans spend their
hard-earned cash catching saw X you can
be sure there'll be more jigsaw to
come